Does your genetic testing include checking for the BRCA gene for breast cancer?
Yes, so the BRCA genes, remember, they're just families of genes.
There's actually dozens and dozens of BRCA genes.
Now, there are just a few really common ones that have been well-researched
that show that show can't be positive for with horrible related cancers.
Like the ovarian cancer or uterine cancer or breast cancer.
But understand, the BRCA genes are tumor suppressor genes.
Having defects on your tumor suppressor genes isn't to cause for cancer.
That doesn't cause cancer.
However, when you have defects on tumor suppressor genes,
you're going to have a decreased sensitivity to your body,
responding when a cell goes into rapid replication,
you'll have a decreased sensitivity in its response time
to stimulate what's called the intrinsic apoptotic pathway.
So apoptosis, normal program cell death.
Well, you can stimulate normal program cell death from the outside of the cell.
Like vitamin D does that.
Attaches to the estrogen beta receptor and stimulates extrinsic,
the extrinsic apoptotic pathway.
That's actually how that works.
And if a person has estrogen receptor and progesterone receptor positive cancer,
you have quote-unquote bad estrogens that attach to that estrogen beta receptor,
blockied vitamin D's desire to attach to that to stimulate the extrinsic apoptotic pathway
thereby to kill the cell.
So again, even having an ER positive cancer, bad estrogens are the cause of the cancer.
Something got inside the cell and caused that DNA damage that is causing the cell replication.
It isn't the fact that you have defects to tumor suppressor genes,
nor isn't the fact that your cancer is ER positive, that you have the cancer.
It's just that those things are decreasing your ability to kill the cancer either
extrinsically from the outside of the cell or intrinsically from the inside of the cell
because the tumor suppressor genes roll when a cell goes into rapid replication,
is to stimulate this cap-sase pathway inside the cell called the intrinsic apoptotic pathway
that causes cell destruction from the inside out.
Well, if I have defects to my tumor suppressor genes, that can be hindered.
That's also why I don't want you to take a bunch of excess methyl groups because if you take
a bunch of excess methyl groups, it actually can silence the tumor suppressor genes.
So, I may not even have any defects on my tumor suppressor genes,
but because I'm taking excess methyl groups, I'm actually turning them off and
hindering my body's ability to stimulate that intrinsic apoptotic pathway.
So, long answer to this question, yes, we're testing for bronca gene defects.
If I'd not noted, understand, if you got your genes back,
it'll be at the end of the, so you got the, you get three reports.
You get the full genetic report, which is like 380 plus pages.
You get the genetic summary report, which is like 20 pages and it would be at the bottom
the end of that genetic summary page.
There's a section where it says tumor suppressor genes.
Now, some people have no defects in any other tumor suppressor genes.
That means, at least from a genetic standpoint,
you have no hindrances of the intrinsic apoptotic pathways function.
From a genetic standpoint, no.
You can have excess methyl groups.
You can have other damage, other toxins in cells that can block that level of law.
But from a genetic standpoint, that's not hindered.
So, if that's not highlighted, the bronca genes are not highlighted on you,
understand the bronca genes are only what a, you know, a couple of dozen different tumor
suppressor genes systems that we look for.
So, I look at all those tumor suppressor genes systems and I'll highlight the ones
where you have a lot of defects.
And then there's some interventions that may go along with it.
So, it would be at the end of that end of that genetic summary page.
So, even in the full genetic 380 page,
I think there's, you don't see the bronca genes, you don't see any of the other tumor suppressor genes,
the argenetic workup tests for literally 90,000 genes.
I mean, it would be, it would be too many pages to even put in there.
So, when I'm looking for the tumor suppressor genes,
they're not even in the normal.
I have to search, I'm searching for them.
So, it takes a long time to do your genetic workup.
Because I have to search for each one of them.
So, that's what you would look for.
I got my results written, but did not see it.
I have so many cognitive issues with Lyme that I have not been able to listen to the classes
or read about it.
Thank you.
So, just look at the genetic summary.
I know that not everybody's real nerdy and wants to dig in to all these pages.
It's like, just tell me what to do.
Big, damn it.
I get it.
So, you don't want to look at the genetic summary.
Just look at the genetic action steps.
That's the only three page.
That's why we did this.
I understand that not everybody's like,
wanting to get in this and learn all those stuff.
So, you know, go to sex.
That's what you're the doctor when I'm done.
I get it.
But I also feel like my colleague is to be a teacher.
So, I always try to teach you guys.
So, just we try to summarize as much as possible.
So, the sheet course and all those videos are just for people who really want to dirt out.
And that's why we have very few views on that.
Because, you know, we've...